Ukrainian officials say more
than 500 people,
including 28
children, have been rescued so far.
From flooded villages
along the Disney River.
But the areas near
the devastating dam collapse
remain under active shelling,
making every rescue attempt
extra seemingly dangerous.
Have a listen to this
and the rest of the
president.
Zelensky surveyed the destruction
for himself on Thursday and said
rescue crews
were working nonstop to reach
as many stranded people as possible.
In his nightly address, Mr.
Zelensky had harsh
words for Russia's leader.
By doing this manmade disaster
at the Nova,
Coca Hydro
electricity plant
is not a natural disaster
or a manifestation of the climate crisis.
The disaster is Putin.
What he does,
what he personally orders to do.
Meanwhile, Russia's military claims
its forces
were engaged in a major battle
early Thursday in the Zappa
region region.
We get more now from CNN's Fred Pleitgen
live
in a program of
breaking news on Kremlin controlled TV,
claiming Moscow's forces are facing
massive attacks in southern Ukraine.
That is no grounds give us.
Ukrainian forces
attacked with naito tanks
and light armored vehicles.
Our army has fought off these attacks
Russia's defense ministry
releasing aerial videos
like this one, allegedly
showing their forces
targeting advancing
Ukrainian formations
in the Zakariya region.
Moscow also claims to have taken out
a modern Western anti-aircraft
radar system close to the front line
on a visit to an arms depot.
Russia's defense minister urging
faster weapons
deliveries to the enemy
tried to advance today, he says.
So this equipment is needed.
Let's hurry up
while the Ukrainians have not confirmed
offensive operations.
And CNN can't independently verify
the specific Russian claims.
U.S.
officials have told CNN
the Russians are putting
up stiff resistance.
Ukraine's leadership says they understand
their counteroffensive
will be long and tough
and they'll need lots of armor
to penetrate. Russia's defenses.
They showed us this
repair and modification shop
where they fix up
mostly vehicles
captured from the Russians,
including this modern troop transporter.
Even with all the Western equipment
that the Ukrainians
have already received,
they still have a lot
less than the Russians do.
That's why
every tank and every armored vehicle
that they can get back on
the battlefield
will be vital for Ukraine's war effort.
That includes even seemingly destroyed
vehicles like this, blown up
armored personnel carrier.
The project manager tells me all this
we can restore and return the units
further along the southern front line.
The situation in the areas
flooded by the recent destruction
of a major dam is deteriorating.
Ukraine and Russia
accusing
each other of targeting operations
to rescue flood victims.
Ukraine's chief Friday
dodging for cover as shells rained down
to bring people here from over the river
and the rest of the
pressure.
The Ukrainians say
several people were wounded in Harrison.
As the authorities
continue to fight
to bring those stranded to safety.
And CNN is offering to Ukraine
now among those on the front lines,
the war in Ukraine
is likely taking a heavy mental toll
on both sides, particularly the Russians.
With new wartime
policies that temporary buyer,
active duty and mobilized soldiers
from leaving service.
Joining me now from Washington
to talk more about this Doremus
Scott
who is senior policy
researcher with the Rand Corporation
and wrote a fascinating article
in The Economist about this.
And you wrote
that Russia is
and will be facing, in your words,
a social crisis of veteran mental
health disorders.
You call it a ticking time bomb.
Explain what you mean.
Why did
so most Russian
soldiers fighting in Ukraine right now,
whether their officers are active duty
or mobilized,
they are prohibited
from leaving the military.
And so they are sitting there
in sustaining combat trauma
with no relief.
Eventually,
these restrictions will be lifted
and they will return back to Russia,
where they are likely to face
inadequate care.
And we know that this population,
if they have sustained combat trauma,
if they do not receive
appropriate care for PTSD,
they are at higher
risk of substance abuse,
domestic problems, job problems,
and they're prone to other
mental disorders
and physical disorders down the road.
Yeah, And I want to
in the
Ukrainian are experiencing this as I was.
I was just going to ask you about that.
And, you know, of course
the Ukrainian people
and military experiencing
PTSD and other traumas as well.
I saw it myself over there.
Are there differences,
though, in how the two sides
deal with the issue?
There
is and so my area
specialty is on the Russian military.
So I wrote about that.
But to describe briefly
what the Ukrainians
are experiencing, it's
not only the Ukrainian military it's
also the Ukrainian people.
So the citizens themselves
have to live in a situation
where their cities are being shelled
or they're under missile strikes.
They've lost loved ones or
their loved ones are fighting,
they've been displaced internally
or they're living abroad now.
So it's really accumulative
and stacking and traumas
that they need help with,
not just military, but also civilian.
The needs are vast. Yeah.
And is there any indication
that Russian authorities are dealing
with the issue in any meaningful way
treating it?
And and how could untreated
or inadequately treated combat trauma
play out in Russian society?
Russia does
not have a strong history
for caring for its combat veterans.
Yeah, this stems from World War Two.
It happened in Afghanistan.
It happened in Chechnya.
They do not receive adequate
care for their physical wounds
or their mental wounds.
And essentially they fall into
they are people with severe PTSD.
And the rest of the Russian society
began to be very afraid of them
and very alienated from them,
which makes the problem worse.
It's a little different now.
There is institutional knowledge
about PTSD in Russia,
and they're taking some preliminary steps
to try to set up
some programs for these veterans
once they return home.
But I think it's going to be overwhelmed
by sheer numbers. Yeah.
And we mentioned,
you know, that
Russian law now makes it illegal
to not just leave the service,
but to discredit or criticize
the armed forces.
Is that likely to discourage soldiers
from even seeking treatment
or being honest
about their conditions
when they have that sort of thing
in front of them?
It is so.
Mental health
wellness is not really something
that's part of Russian military culture
right now.
So most soldiers are probably not going
to even seek out that type of care.
They'll tend to
deal with it on their own, whether that's
through alcoholism or social isolation.
But for those who do reach out,
given the climate in Russia right now,
there are Russian therapists
who may not want to work
with this population.
They may object to the war morally
or they may not want to overhear
a patient say or discuss things
like war crimes
or things they witnessed or did
that could potentially
put that therapist
in some kind of legal liability
So there's there's
many layers to this thing
where it's
not a particularly neutral environment
for those who even see that.
That's a really important point.
We're nearly out of time.
But I wanted to ask you, you know,
with its control over the media
in the crushing of any dissent,
the Kremlin has long
fought to keep the impact of the war
on Russia from Russians
from the general population.
Is there any sign of cracks
in that strategy?
And as you know, people with PTSD
come home.
Is that likely to
contribute to any cracks
Absolutely.
I mean, it's in the West.
It's called a Stop-Loss policy,
where people can't leave
the military service
because at war,
because of the numbers
that are stable or holding,
eventually these people will be released
back to their towns
and villages across Russia.
And so these problems will be there,
whether they want to admit it now or not.
Currently,
the Russians are not discussing
how many casualties are out there.
The numbers they have
are artificially low,
even though burials are being conducted
in the open.
People know the numbers are not accurate.
All of these, the fuzes lit.
All of these chickens
are going to come home to roost. Yeah.
Daryn Mascot, always great to get you on.
And your analysis,
great piece in The Economist.
People should read it. Thank you.
Thank you very much.